[Musique]
la montagne ça vous gagne ce slogan
colle parfaitement à mon invité ancienne
monitrice de ski c'est pour défendre son
village de montagne qu'elle s'est engagé
en politique un combat pour ces
territoires enclavés qu'elle mène
aujourd'hui en tant que
[Musique]
député bon bonjour marie-oë Battistel
bonjour alors vous êtes aujourd'hui
député du groupe socialiste mais à vos
tout début ce n'est pas pour défendre
les idées d'un parti que vous êtes
engagé il y a un élément déclencheur
c'est un un drame qui a frappé votre
village de la salle en baaumont en iszer
c'était dans la nuit du 7 au 8 janvier
1994 voici ce qui reste de la partie
haute du village de salembaumont 200
habitants c'était la Maison du Boulanger
et voici où cette nuit s'est arrêté la
nationale 85 la route Napoléon qui relie
ou plutôt reli Grenoble à gape il nous
est arrivé ben ça c'est la montagne qui
est tombée hein pu c'est tout de couples
manque toujours à l'appel leur maison
était là avant le passage d'un mur de
bout de 30 m de haut et 200 m de large
alors quatre personnes sont morte dans
ce glissement de terrain c'est vraiment
ce ce drame là qui a déclenché votre
envie de vous engager en politique oui
tout à fait c'est finalement un
événement tragique dans cette commune où
j'habitais déjà depuis plusieurs années
qui a déclenché mon envie d'aller plus
loin je militais beaucoup dans le monde
associatif à cette époque et on a
évidemment on s'est engagé pour aider
les sinistrés puisqu'il y a eu quatre
personnes décédées mais il y a eu aussi
10 familles qui ont perdu leur maison et
qu'il fallait accompagner et j'ai vite
vu les limites du monde associatif et de
l'action associative pour finalement
ensuite
reconstruire passer à la reconstruction
du village et c'est comme ça que j'ai
décidé de m'engager j'ai euh dans
l'élection municipale de 1995 l'année
suivante où j'ai été élu conseillère
municipal d'opposition avec deux autres
de mes collègues je suis devenu maire en
1998 3 ans plus tard après la démission
du du maire précédent oui parce qu'en
fait le maire a démissionné et alors là
il y a plusieurs élus de sa propre liste
qui ont décidé finalement de voter pour
vous contre toute attente vous êtes donc
devenu maire pendant 19 ans de ce
village vous avez aussi été conseillère
régionale présidente de
l'intercommunalité aujourd'hui député
mais vous dites que c'est ce mandat à la
tête d'un petit village de 300 habitants
que vous avez préféré pourquoi
parce que la proximité pour moi c'est en
fait c'est mon ADN et et c'est vrai que
quel est le le plus beau mandat pour un
élu que celui de maère où on est au
contact des concitoyens tout le temps
j'ai envie de dire matin midi et soir où
on chacun a a notre numéro de portable
et on est Interpel pour toutes les
situations qu'ell soi social ou d'autres
difficultés et on a aussi une capacité
d'agir extrêmement rapide ou quand on
prend des décisions dans une commune de
350 habitants on peut quasiment
l'appliquer le lendemain matin ce qui
est quand même pas le cas quand on est
déput dans notre dans ma mission
d'aujourd'hui effectivement c'est donc
l'effondrement d'une montagne c'est donc
un drame qui est à l'origine de de votre
engagement en politique et quand on
regarde les sujets qui vous mobilisent
encore aujourd'hui on voit que la
montagne est partout vous avez
d'ailleurs présidé l'ANEM qui est
l'association nationale des élu de
montagne et quand vous en parlez vous
présentez cette association comme le
parti de la montagne c'estàdire que
quand on est élu de montagne il y a plus
de droite de gauche de centre on est on
défend tous le oui les les combat de la
montagne sont transpartisans et en fait
effectivement ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé
dans cette dans cette association
c'était vraiment d'avoir une un
rassemblement d'élus quel que soit le
leur bord politique qui porte les mêmes
valeurs et la même défense de ces
territoires de montagne et la défense de
la spécif icité montagnard qui est quand
même un sujet extrêmement
important pour les gens qui y vivent qui
est vraiment difficile à faire entendre
à l'Assemblée je peux vous le dire moi
je ça fait 13 ans que je suis député et
j'ai l'impression que je rabâche de
manière permanente que la spécificité de
la montagne doit être prise en compte ce
qui n'est pas du tout toujours le cas en
2007 vous avez franchi une nouvelle
étape on peut dire dans votre engagement
avec Didier Migot qui vous a proposé de
devenir sa
suppléante il se trouve que 3 ans plus
tard Didier MIGO a était nommé à à la
présidence de la de la Cour des comptes
et à ce moment-là il a fallu trouver
quelqu'un au sein du PS pour lui
succéder et le Parti socialiste vous a
choisi vous vous vous y attendiez pas du
tout pourquoi vous vous projetiez pas
dans dans ce mandat là de député c'était
bah la petite anecdote c'est que lorsque
j'ai accepté d'être la supplante de
Didier Migot j'étais d'ailleurs surprise
qu'il viennent à l'époque me solliciter
et je lui avais dit très bien mais ne
sois jamais ministre parce que je ne
souhaite pas être député et et 3 ans
après il avait tenu son engagement il
n'a pas été ministre mais enfin il a d a
cas de figure que vous aviez pas
anticipé pas du tout du tout du tout et
il a dû démissionner et la question
s'est posée de
comment qui qui pour lui succéder j'ai
donc eu une semaine pour réfléchir
est-ce que est-ce que je m'engage dans
ce mandat qui était absolument pas prévu
pour moi est-ce que j'ai suffisamment de
de temps et de capacité pour m'y
investir pleinement et puis l'aventure
était sement trop belle à tenté et j'ai
accepté de le faire et j'ai été soutenu
effectivement par le Parti socialiste
parce qu'à l'époque je n'étais pas
socialiste c'était pas une condition que
m'avait posé Didier Migot pour pour
partir avec lui dans cette aventure et
donc vous avez été élu
réélu et vous-même vous avez dû choisir
un suppléant alors les liens entre un
député et son suppléant peuvent être
très forts mais la politique elle est
aussi faite de trahison et vous avez
connu cela en 2017 on était à un mois
des législatives quand votre suppléant
non seulement a changé de bord il a
rejoint Emmanuel Macron mais il s'est
présenté face à vous aux
législativ comment comment on se remet
d'un d'un coup pareil B d'abord on est
un peu surpris on est un peu sous le
choc de se dire bon s'il me l'avait dit
6 mois ou un an avant bon voilà je me
sens plus plus bien au sein du Parti
socialiste et j'envisage de rejoindre
Emmanuel Macron bon benah très bien
chacun fait sa voix et là ça a été quand
même assez soudain j étais pas forcément
préparé et puis on avait pas beaucoup de
temps pour trouver un autre suppléant et
puis se relancer dans cette dynamique ça
ça ça coupe la dynamique quand même et
et de se relancer dans cette campagne
bon nous l'avons fait nous avvez nous
avons relevé le défi et aujourd'hui j'ai
un suppléant extrêmement fidèle qui
m'accompagne et et et voilà les choses
sont passées mais c'est vrai que c'est
la politique est parfois difficile et
surtout ça a failli bah vous coûter
votre votre siège à l'Assemblée parce
que au soir du premier tour de cette
élection votre ancien suppléant avait 14
points d'avance sur vous tout le monde
pensait qu'il allait qu'il allait gagner
au au second tour et pourtant vous
l'avez emporté et vous l'avez emporté
avec 8 point d'avance sur lui euh je
crois qu'il y a plusieurs élus de droite
qui avaient appelé à l'époque à voter
pour vous dans l'entre de tour est-ce
que vous diriez que c'est ce que vous
appelez justement le parti de la
montagne qui vous a aidé à à remporter
cette élection oui je crois que c'est un
peu ça euh ça a fait partie de de de la
de cette réussite collective j'ai j'ai
l'habitude de dire que cette campagne ça
a été la plus difficile de par ces
événements mais aussi la plus belle
parce que c'était une victoire
collective avec un rassemblement d'élus
et de citoyens qui n'était pas forcément
de mon camp politique mais qui ont qui
ont voulu marquer le fait que bah ça ne
se fait pas d'avoir un comportement
comme ça à la dernière minute et puis
les montagnards se sont aussi mobilisés
en disant euh textuellement un élu m'a
dit non c'est pas possible on ne peut
pas perdre notre député de montagne et
et et donc il y a eu effectivement une
forte mobilisation combat vous avez mené
au nom habit voà et puis la proximité
avec laquelle je traitais les les sujets
de manière régulière et donc je suis
passée effectivement de 19 % au 1ier
tour à 58 au 2e tour ce qui est un grand
saut depuis 2022 vous siégez dans une
assemblée qui n'a pas de majorité
absolue une assemblée qui est quand même
plus agitée on va dire que les que les
précédentes il y a beaucoup de députés
et de ministres qui s'en plainent qui
parlent même de bordélisation de
l'Assemblée vous vous vous en plaignez
pas pourquoi c'est pas que je ne m'en
plains pas il y a des moments qui sont
difficiles mais moi je trouve plus
d'intérêt à ce mandat que le mandat
précédent puisque il y avait une
tellement forte majorité
qu'effectivement la parole de
l'opposition était réduite à néant là on
a quand même une capacité à agir
lorsque la majorité recherche une
majorité effectivement vous avez créé
votre entreprise de transport peu de
temps après votre première candidature
au au municipal vous en êtes resté la
patronne pendant longtemps y compris
après votre élection à l'Assemblée on
vous voit d'ailleurs au volant d'un de
vos autocars
ici c'est compliqué de gérer une
entreprise tout en étant député
oui enfin chacun peut comprendre que
c'est extrêmement difficile vous l'avez
fait pendant plusieurs années quandê à
l'époque j'étais maire de la commune de
la Salomon aussi puisqu'il y avait pas
la loi sur le non cumul des mandats mais
lorsque je suis arrivé en
2010 ça faisait 3 ans que j'avait que je
m'étais lancé dans cette aventure
de d'entreprise de transport avec un
associé et donc j'étais élu censé être
élu pour de années donc je me suis
dit sécité voilà et puis en
2012 après avoir vu pendant 2 ans ce qui
se passait à l'Assemblée et puis voir un
certain nombre d'élus qui me
paraissaient assez déconnecté des choses
de la réalité et du quotidien des gens
je me suis dit que c'était important
pour moi de garder cette entreprise de
garder cette activité de voir mes
salariés le le lundi matin ou le
vendredi et de rester ancré dans le
concret de du monde économique et et du
coup j'ai fait ce choix alors que
j'aurais pu évidemment arrêter de de
travailler la député conduisait
régulièrement l'autocar ou oui je
faisais transport Scola aussi alors les
enfants étaient d'un calme plat lorsque
je montais
au m arrivé très très régulièrement
effectivement vous dites aussi que vous
avez créé cette entreprise parce que
vous n'avez pas le tempérament pour
travailler pour les autres alors on peut
compr prend aussi que ça corresponde
aussi à à votre goût pour ce mandat de
maire mais alors quand on est député
est-ce que c'est pas un peu plus
compliqué d'avoir ce tempérament là
alors je pense que c'est bon d'avoir du
tempérament quoi qu'il arrive en tout
cas nous dans notre parti nous avons
quand même l'indépendance de position
lorsqu'il y a vraiment un sujet qui nous
tient à cœur et qui ne fait pas partie
de la ligne politique globale de de
l'ensemble de notre groupe on a quand
même cette liberté de pouvoir à la fois
s'exprimer et puis donner sa position à
titre personnel h et donc moi je trouve
ma place de manière très facile au sein
du du groupe dans lequel je siège mais
c'est vrai que je suis assez
indépendante de tempérament et
que lorsque j'ai je suis dans un travail
ou une mission qui ne me convient plus
je préfère en partir plutôt que de mal
le faire alors on va passer au quiz à
présent vous allez devoir compléter
trois phrases que je vais vous vous
proposer on commence par entre
montagnard à l'Assemblée
entre montagnard à l' ou entre élu de
montagne pas montagnard au sens de la de
la Révol à l'Assemblée et bien il y a
une espèce de de connivance et de
complicité et de et de partage des mêmes
convictions et donc comme je le disais
tout à l'heure une actionou le
dépassement d'éclivagees y compris dans
l'hémicycle faire de la politique c'est
comme conduire un
autocar je vous laisse compléter comme
quand dirait un autocard il y a des
risques oui on l'a vu on l'a vu tout à
l'heure euh c'est un une fonction
puisque là on est sur une fonction
plutôt qu' un métier exigeant où on a
pas forcément le droit à l'erreur ni au
volant d'un quart ni à la tribune parce
que tous nos mots sont tépluché et et
commenté donc j'ai envie de dire que ces
deux métiers exigeants enfin le prochain
suppléant qui me
trahit qu'est-ce qui lui arrivera il en
aura plus puisque il a vu que ça ne
marchait pas il aura vu que ça ne
marchait pas il est il est averti le
supplément que vous avez choisi
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ne me trahira
jamais et il a comme moi à ce stade pas
le souhait d'être député comme je
l'étais précédemment bon merci beaucoup
Marie Noë baptistel d'être venue dans la
politique et
[Musique]
moi